more than 53 million americans are
expected to be traveling for
thanksgiving but there are concerns
holiday gatherings could make the
pandemic worse hospitalizations are
already ticking up again and a new
consensus forecast from the cdc predicts
an acceleration in hospital admissions
in the next few weeks er dr megan randy
joins us now from providence rhode
island to talk about how we can all stay
safe dr randy welcome and happy
thanksgiving good to see you again
so
let's talk about your advice for people
gathering today especially if there are
some folks who are not vaccinated
so thank you vladimir happy thanksgiving
to all of you as well there are really
two things you can do to keep yourself
safe the first is to reduce the risk
that anybody at your gathering is
infectious and doesn't know it and the
second is to reduce the risk of spread
if somebody does somehow slip through
those defenses that you have to keep
everyone safe
for the first part the best thing is
vaccination and boosters if eligible but
it's a little late today if you're not
vaccinated already so what i'm
recommending to all families including
my own is that you buy those rapid
antigen tests at the drugstore they take
about 15 minutes to get results really
easy directions and they provide an
added layer of security that no one
who's showing up at your gathering is
actively infectious
for the second part which is reducing
the risk oh sorry go ahead vlad no go
ahead dr randy sorry i was going to say
the second thing is if to reduce the
risk of spread
you can obviously wear masks but that's
awfully tough with turkey and stuffing
so instead you can open windows or even
consider taking the gathering outside
so that's the advice for folks that are
gathering for thanksgiving what concerns
you most though in the weeks and months
ahead
so i'm definitely worried about these
gatherings being a source of spread of
the virus we know there are already
surges across the northeast and the
north
and as an er doc i can tell you our
hospitals are already overwhelmed with
all of the sickness all of the demand
that got pent up during kovid you know
my own state
our director of our department of health
asked folks to avoid the emergency
department if possible
the state just above me massachusetts
has canceled many elective surgeries
even a small surge in kovid right now is
going to put our hospitals absolutely
over the edge
dr randy less than 20 percent of
americans who are eligible for booster
shots have received them i've seen some
doctors suggesting a population of
unvaccinated and vaccinated folks could
mean a mutation in a virus and another
variant in the spring does that concern
you
it absolutely does as long as we have
these big pockets of unvaccinated people
it serves as a perfect petri dish for
mutations the one positive depending on
how you look at it is that this delta
variant spreads so easily it is crowding
out any other mutations right now but
there's certainly the chance for
something worse and our best protection
against that is vaccinating not just the
us but also the rest of the globe
dr megan randy always good to see you
happy thanksgiving thank you